As I mentioned last class, there are
three major questions that will
determine how this war is fought, what
they what this war uh will end up
looking like, and how the world will
change.
And um as I discussed last class, I'm
making three predictions about this war.
The first is United States will use
ground troops. Um, and this will mean
that Donald Trump will institute a
national draft. Okay, that's the first
prediction. Second prediction is that
Israel and United States will not use
tactical nuclear weapons in this war.
Number three is that the Alaxic Moss,
the third holiest site in the Islamic
world, will be destroyed during this
war. Okay. So, last class I explained my
analysis and my reasoning for
um my first two predictions. Today I'll
explain my uh third prediction. So, but
before we start, I just want to look at
some videos, okay? So, you understand
some of the context, some of the players
in this war. All right? So this is
Senator Bloomthal of Connecticut and he
is one of the hundred members of the US
Senate. He's also one of the members of
the gang of eight. Now um when when you
are fighting a war, the White House has
responsibility to report its um
objectives, its purpose, um how the war
is progressing to eight members of
Congress in a confidential setting.
Okay. And this is um
Senator Bloomthal after he's been
debriefed by the White House. Okay. And
this is what he has to say about the
progress of the war so far.
>> I emerge from this briefing
as dissatisfied
and angry, frankly, as I have from any
past briefing in my 15 years in the
Senate. I am
left with more questions than answers,
especially about the cost of the war.
My questions
have been unanswered
and I will demand answers because the
American people deserve to know. And
I guess I am most
concerned about the threat to American
lives
of potentially deploying our sons and
daughters on the ground in Iran. We seem
to be on a path toward deploying
American troops on the ground in Iran to
accomplish any of the potential
objectives here.
And
There is also,
as disturbingly as anything else, the
spectre of active Russian aid to Iran
putting in danger American lives.
>> All right. So, three things to take away
from
uh his talk with reporters. Okay. First
thing is
the administration, Donald Trump, the
White House has not articulated a
budget. How much will this war cost?
Which means that this is an open-ended
war. We don't know when this war will
end and so we don't know what the
commitment is and so we don't know how
much this war will cost. Okay, that's
the first point he makes. The second
point he makes is we are on a path
towards the deployment of ground troops
in Iran. Okay. And that basically means
a national draft. The third thing that's
crucial is he says that they know for a
fact that Russia is already involved in
this war aiding Iran. Okay. So that's
the three main takeaways from
um
okay so this is um um the foreign
minister of Iran Agachi talking to NBC
News. All right. And NBC News is going
to ask Agachi, hey, there's talk United
States already of ground troops being
used against uh Iran. Okay. Now, I want
you to observe his response and then the
response of the journalists.
President Trump has not ruled out boots
on the ground in Iran. Are you afraid of
a US invasion in your country? No, we
are waiting for them.
>> You you were waiting for the US military
to invade the ground troops.
>> Yes. Because we are confident that we
can confront them and that would be a
big disaster for them.
>> Okay. Do you understand? Okay.
>> So, you're saying that that Iran is
ready and willing to take on the US
military if there were to be ground
troops?
>> Well, we were ready for this. Okay. So
again certain things to appreciate.
First of all the foreign minister I got
you he is not at all concerned about
ground troops. In fact he basically said
it's a trap for you guys. You come in
we've been preparing for about 20 years
for this. We will destroy you. Another
thing that you will notice is the
journalist is completely surprised
by the answer. He's shocked into
silence. He has to ask again, wait, are
you saying you're ready for ground
troops? And so this shows you that
within Washington DC, okay, within uh
the Trump administration, within the
foreign policy elite, within the media
elite, they haven't really fought this
out. They really haven't haven't
considered the possibility of losing
this war. Why should we see right now
it's a bubble? Okay, it's an insular
bubble where everyone just believes the
same things and that's very problematic.
Um, if you are to continue fighting this
war. Okay. All right. Let's continue.
Okay. This is um
um Rabbi Sneersonen
and he is the leader or he used to be he
he's died but he used to be a leader of
an organization called the Shabbat
Lubovich. I'll be talking more about
Shabbat Lubovich as we go along. Okay.
But I introduce you to him now this year
1990 and he is talking to Benjamin
Netanyahu who is who is a young and up
upcoming uh politician in Israel. Okay.
And so let's look at the conversation.
55.
Okay. So, what's going on here? Okay. So
as an upand cominging politician,
Netanyahu is going to the rabbi and the
rabbis are the most powerful people in
the Jewish society. He basically says,
"Will you give me your blessing? Will
you support me in my political
endeavors?" The rabbi says, "Yes." They
also talk about how things are
progressing. Okay. So, another way we're
saying this is that there's almost like
a plan in motion to achieve certain
religious objectives and things are
going well, but the uh rabbi says, "Ah,
but they're not going fast enough
because we need the Messiah,
the great leader of the Jewish people to
come." And we can set in motion things
that will force the coming of the
Messiah. So, let's speed things up.
Netanyahu.
Okay. So, what this is, I'll explain
later on. Okay. But I want you to be
aware of this who these people are. Rabi
is very important for our story. And
Nahu, of course, is the current prime
minister of Israel.
All right. Let's continue.
All right.
We want to know what you're reading now.
>> What I'm reading?
>> Yeah. of the Jews against Rome.
>> What made you pick it up?
>> Well, we lost it. I think we have to win
the next
>> We want to know what you're reading now.
>> Okay.
All right. So, that's a very quick
exchange. Okay. So, a journalist is
asking Benjamin Netanyahu, "What book
are you reading now?" And he says, "Jews
versus, sorry, Rome versus the Jews."
It's a book by Barry Strauss, a
historian, and it goes about goes on
about the three wars that the Jews
fought against the Romans, and it was
essentially a holocaust for the Jews. A
lot of Jews either died or were
enslaved. The Romans burned down the
second temple. So there's this
historical animosity of the Jews against
the Romans. Okay. But what you but but
what he said is what what Ben Netanyahu
said is that I'm reading this book
because we lost that war against Rome.
But the next war against Rome, we must
not lose. The question then is who's
Rome?
It's not Iran, guys. It's probably not
Russia. It's probably America, right?
The great empire. So this is strange
because Israel is the ally of America in
this war but Nanyahu is saying that
no our real enemy is Rome and that's
what we must prepare for. Okay so I want
you guys to keep this in mind. All right
this is Peter Hexf who is a secretary of
war for uh Donald Trump. Okay. And this
is the year about 2018
uh where he is in Jerusalem and he's
talking to Christian Zionist and
Zionist. Okay. Who these people are I'll
explain later on. Okay. But let's let's
listen to his speech really quickly.
and I and others had a chance to go see
the western wall of the temple mount,
the western wall tunnels, uh so much of
the old city. And as you stand there,
you can't help but behold the miracle
before you. And it got me thinking about
another miracle that I hope all of you
don't see too far away because 1917 was
a miracle. 1948 was a miracle. 1967 was
a miracle. 2017, the declaration of
Jerusalem as the capital was a miracle.
And there's no reason why the miracle of
the reestablishment of the temple on the
temple mount is not possible.
Okay? So, he is a Christian. He's not a
Jew. But what he's saying is that he's
come to Jerusalem and he's visited these
Jewish holy sites and he can't be he
can't help be be amazed beed by the
beauty the spirituality of the western
wall. He also goes on to say that the
there's been a series of miracles. Okay.
So 1917 was the buffer declaration when
basically uh the British Empire
permitted the Jews to found the nation
state of Israel. 1948 was when Israel
was founded. 1967 was when the the when
Israel fought a war against its
neighbors and won. Okay. in 2017 was
when Donald Trump transferred the
American embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem, thus recognizing Jerusalem as
the capital of uh Israel. And what he's
saying is that well if this is a series
of steps to achieving a divine plan then
the next miracle should be the
rebuilding of someone's temple the third
temple and that means destroying the
Isaac mosque. Okay. So what's going on
here? Okay. Again I'll explain to you
later on but I want I want you to be
aware of who these people are and how
they think. All right. Let's go one more
video. And so if you want to build uh
someone's temple, if you want to build
the third temple, you need to get rid of
the third holiest site in the seven
world. And how do you do that? Well,
there are some options. Okay, so
missiles will hit the mosque.
and clear the place for the third beta
mikdash. That could also be a miracle.
>> If it was up to me, the last time when
they shot hundreds of missiles, I would
pretend that one missile came from Iran
and shoot it down.
You know, then all the Arabs will go
against Iran. It will be the end of the
problems. You make them fight with each
other. this bunch of lunatics.
>> Never too late. You deal with a bunch of
cowards.
>> Okay, so this is a rabbi in Israel. He's
saying how last year during the 12th day
war in June um Iran was firing missiles
um at Israel. And what he's saying is,
you know, that was an opportunity for us
to pretend the Iranian missile hit the
Dome of the Rock, the Actic Mos, thus
destroying it. And then we'll the Arabs
will blame the Iranians and the Arabs
will go to war against the Persians. And
then we can just sit back and laugh at
these lunatics.
Okay? So again, this may be confusing to
you as to who these people are, why they
are saying these things. All right? But
now what what I'm going to do is explain
to you what is really going on. Okay?
And I keep on saying this, but it is
hard from a from a geopolitical
perspective to explain this US Iran war.
You have to look at the religious
perspective. Okay? The religious angle.
And that's what I want to focus on
today.
Okay,
sorry.
Okay, so again
this is the three holiest site in the
Islamic world. Um, this is Saudi Arabia,
Mecca Medina. And this is
the
Dome of the Rock, the Alaxic Mosque,
which is where Muhammad was supposed to
ascend to heaven. And the Jews and the
Christian Zionists believe that this
must be destroyed so that they can build
the third temple or Solomon's temple.
Okay. All right. So this is the big
question in this war and again I I hate
I I keep on saying this but I need to be
right in my prediction. If my analysis
is to be correct if they do not destroy
the moss and if they are able to achieve
peace
then my predictive model my analysis is
completely wrong and you just ignore me
okay for the rest of my life and I can I
can go back to teaching you know the
great books or something. All right. So
let us examine
um why this is important. Okay. So today
I want to introduce you to a new theory
of game theory called the law of
esquetological convergence.
Okay. So this is a very hard thing to
write down. Okay, it sounds complicated
but it's not. Okay, esquetology
what it is is a story of how the world
ends.
And it's very comp and it's it's very
compelling for people because remember
we discussed this last semester but as
human beings we have three questions.
Where do we come from?
Why are we here? Where are we going? And
esquetology
provides a story that answers all three
questions. Why God created us? What our
mission on earth is? And what God has
planned for the end of the world. Okay.
And different traditions will have
different esquetologies.
And what's important to uh figure out is
in what aspect
do these esquetologies converge. Okay,
converge meaning a union of these
esquetologies.
And why is that important? Because it
allows you to predict how they will
behave. Think of a story as the
operating system of a society.
And as such, it's a script that they
will act out. And if you're able to
figure out the different scripts and see
how they converge together, where the
union of these different scripts are,
then you can actually predict how the
world will turn out. Okay. All right.
So, having explained the law, um I'm
going to go into some theory to help us
understand um why this is why this
works. Okay. All right. So the first
thing to understand is something called
the universal
law of game theory.
Okay? And the universal law of game
theory states this. Whoever wins a game
is able to do this. Okay? mass
times
um energy
coordination.
Okay, so these are the three things you
want to look at to understand how well a
player would do in a game. So mass is
just the number number of people
involved
um on the team. Okay, energy is just how
much attention, focus, motivation there
is. Okay, so think of think of it as
attention
or motivation
or action. Okay, any of these words will
do. But basically, how how invested are
you in winning the game and how willing
how hard are you willing to work to win
the game? And coordination is just the
idea of synchronicity. And what I mean
by that is how well
do the teammates work together.
Okay. And something that you need to
appreciate is that the most important
thing in war in winning a game is
actually coordination. In fact, I would
say it's four times more important than
just mass. So you can have a lot of
people, but if they don't work well
together, you're defeated by another
team with few few people, but they work
well together. Okay? And an energy is
twice as important as mass. All right?
So let me give an example. Let's just
say that you're playing a game by
yourself. Okay? May maybe for example,
you enter a ping- pong competition or a
chess competition. Well, mass and
coordination don't really matter cuz you
don't have any teammates. And so what
matters is energy. How motivated you are
to win this game. How much time do you
put in practice? How much time do you
put into studying and improving
yourself? How how focused are you in
winning? Okay. All right. So a team
sport uh well mass is constant and so
what matters is energy and coordination.
How well the team works uh well
together. Okay. Now um what's
interesting is that there are different
ways to
improve or increase augment the energy
and coordination. All right. So maybe um
a leader.
Okay. So maybe if someone is a really
inspiring leader that will make people
much more motivated and that will allow
them to work well together because all
they have to do is listen to a leader.
Okay. The problem with leader of course
is that eventually he will die.
All right. Then you have a family. Okay.
Blood.
Okay. Um they work well together because
they all share similar blood. But we
cannot account for the differences
within this family. The conflict within
this family, right? So historically in
the long term um the force that allows
teams to beat other teams is the idea of
narrative.
Okay, narrative
or a story.
Okay, why? because it implants in the
minds of all those who believe in a
narrative a series of actions that they
must take in order to win the game.
Okay? So, think of it as a script and in
a script you know what part you play.
So, you just have to act it out and that
allows for you all to work together to
achieve the outcome that you desire.
Okay, does that make sense? Okay. And in
narrative, the most powerful
uh form of narrative is the idea of
esquetology.
Because esquetology is a complete
script,
a complete script in which everyone
knows
what he or she must do in order to
achieve the desired outcome. And as
esquetology also is able to transcend
both time and space, meaning that um you
can actually spend centuries acting out
the script because everyone knows his
role anyway. Okay? And it can transcend
borders as well. You can you can go
beyond ethnic identity and family. Okay?
So the most powerful mechanism in
history is esquetology. All right. So
what is esettology?
All right. So
most religions
are similar. Most religions require you
to be a good person. Be humble. Be kind.
Be generous.
But there are certain aspects of
religions that are extreme. Okay? And we
we call them esquetologies.
Okay. So, the classic example is a
Jewish religion. Okay. In the Jewish
religion, if you're um what you believe
is that you you no longer live in Israel
because a long time ago, the Israelites
pissed off God by disobeying him. God
told the Israelites, "Do not worship
false idols." But the Israelites sinned.
They disobeyed. So they were kicked out
of Jerusalem and they were forced to
wander the earth in a diaspora for
centuries. And so what they believe is
that they each need to engage in an act
of redemption, of humility,
of submission, of piety to God if they
are to redeem the whole Jewish people.
Okay? And when that happens, when they
recognize their own limitations, when
they recognize um how inferior they are
to God and submit to God, then God will
send the Messiah
to redeem them and lead them back to
Jerusalem, defeat the enemies of the
Jews, bring all the Jews from the Dash
back to Jerusalem, unifying the Jewish
people, and then build the third temple
so that God can come to earth and live
with all the Jews and create heaven on
earth. Okay, that is the um Jewish
religion that most Jews believe. Okay,
like there are a lot of differences.
Okay, but but I'm just trying to
simplify it for clarity. Okay, but then
you have these extremes
fanatics
who have a different esquetology. Okay,
and these people we can say are
accelerationists.
And what and their point is that
this is fine, but it's way too slow
and it dissolves us of individual
responsibility. If you have faith in
God, then you should want to hurry
things up and um force the return of God
as soon as possible. And you do that by
recognizing that
um
if you actually before the Messiah
comes, if you actually go and create the
nations of Israel, bring all the Jews
back, build the third temple, defeat all
the enemies, then the Messiah will come
naturally.
Okay? And so, of course, most Jews hear
this and they think that this is
blasphemy. It's heresy because you are
defying the will of God. You think you
can manipulate God into action. That is
wrong. That is the opposite of
redemption. That is the worst possible
sin you can make. Okay? And so this
esquetology is considered a fringe, an
extreme, something to be ignored. The
problem though is that if you think
about it, what an esquetology really is
doing is creating a vector board
to force the religion to move in a
certain direction.
Okay? And also if you think about it, if
this is a case where esquetology is a
vector that forces the mainstream to
move in a certain direction,
then whichever esquetology is the most
extreme, the most violent
will be the one that wins out. Okay?
Okay. Does that make sense? In other
words, what we're going to do today is
look at the most extreme versions of
different esquetologies.
Because quite honestly, even though
these extreme versions are shared by
only a few people, they're the ones who
are working the hardest to achieve their
esquetology and therefore they're
forcing the religion they are in to move
a certain way.
Okay. All right. So, um, you hear this
and you think this all confusing, but
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
share with you
a passage from a biography of Rabbi Sn.
Remember we um we had a look at Rabbi
Snerson talking to Nam saying, "Hurry
up. Let's hurry up the return of the
Messiah." Okay. Um he is uh in charge of
Shabbat Lubaridge
which again
is an extreme esquetology but again
because they are so extreme there's
willing they're willing to work as hard
as possible to achieve their vision and
therefore they are forcing the Jewish
mainstream in a certain direction. Okay.
All right. So um this is a biography of
Rabbi Sneer
and the Shabbat Lubich movement um was
founded in modernday uh Barus
and over time it went over to America
because it suffered a lot of persecution
um by the Russians and today they are a
global movement and they are powerful in
Russia in America and in Israel. Okay.
So, we will discuss Shab Lubich as we
move along, but I want to with this
passage show you
how coordination among estologologists
work. Okay. All right. So, so the year
is 1939
and the Nazis, Nazi Germanies again who
are anti-semitic, they hate Jews, they
want all Jews out of Europe. They are
overrunning Europe and by 1939 they have
conquered Poland Warsaw.
Okay. Now Poland Warsaw is where the
head rabbi the rebat
lubber movement is and his name is um
Yseph Yazat. Okay. And he's the
father-in-law of Rabbi Snersen.
and he's an old man and he's in Warsaw
and the Nazis are overrunning the city.
So his followers in America are
want to save his life. Okay. So then the
question then is like but how do you do
that? Because America and Germany are
not best friends. The war is breaking
out in um Europe and
um Yseph Yitz
is a very old man and there are no plane
well there are planes but there are no
commercial airflights that you can take.
Okay. So it's going to be a very long
arduous journey across many borders plus
um he will need a visa not just for
himself but for his whole family. Okay.
Now what I'll show you is how powerful
these people are and again this is an
esquetology where they all share similar
vision and therefore they're willing to
make the necessary sacrifices in order
to help each other achieve this vision.
Okay. All right. So this is from the
biography in ocean way in America. Yet's
followers were mounting a rescue effort
with the help of Sad Kramer and an orth
orthodox attorney and the son of Luber
immigrants. The Shabbat activist Israel
Jacobsum hired Max Road a political
connected lawyer to secure American
visas for Yseph Uitz and his family.
Okay. So in other words, even though
there may may not be that many
followers, they have a wide
uh political circle and a lot of reason
why is that um they pull their resources
together and when they pull their
resources together, they're able to
invest in real estate together. They're
able to invest in business together and
they're able to generate a lot of money
which they can then which they can then
use to influence politics in America.
Okay? They can buy politicians. they can
um do a lot of things. Okay, so the
first part is easy. Getting visas for uh
the rabbi and his family. Now the
problem is how do you actually
get to him? Okay, cuz there are no
telephones, there's no internet, there
are no airplanes. How do you find him in
when there's a war going on in Poland
when there are Nazis everywhere? Okay.
All right, let's continue. Yseph uh
Uritz's followers also reached out to
Attorney General Benjamin Cohen. Okay.
And Supreme Court Justice Lie Brandai.
Okay. This guy, this man is very
important. He's what I call Sabatine
Frankus.
What I will show you later on is that uh
Sabatine Frankus and the Shab Litz
movement are very much aligned. Okay. So
even though they're part of the same
movement, they are sympathetic towards
each other. And he's the most powerful
Jew in America at this time. Okay. In
the 1930s,4s.
um whom yitz had met during his
fundraising trip of 1929. The lava's
efforts in America were successful. All
right. So they won over the Americans.
They they've won over the entire
American political apparatus and they
are dedicated to helping the rabbi
escape Europe and come to America. All
right. Now the second part is how do you
deal with the Nazis? Okay. The libert's
efforts in America were successful. On
October 2nd, Cohen wrote to Robert Pal,
a senior official in the state
department, asking for help. The next
day, Pal Helmouth Wadhat, a German and a
member of the Nazi party, a Nazi who
specialized in nationalist industry and
economics to see if he would be willing
to save one of the leading Jewish
scholars in the world. Okay, this is a
guy, American, where he's a Nazi and
saying, "Hey man, uh, I know you're
Nazi, but we need your help to save a
Jew." And the guy says, "Yes." Okay.
Um, Wilhhat was strategically chosen. He
had studied at Columbia University in
the early 1930s and had forged a
relationship with PEL after the Evian
Conference on Jewish Refugees in 1938.
Um, seeing an opportunity to curry
goodwill the United States, W had
secretly contacted Admiral William
Patteras, the head of German military
intelligence. Wow.
The head of German military
intelligence.
and say, "Hey man, let's help this guy."
Caner, a skeptical Nazi who disapproved
of SS atrocities and thought the
invasion pulled in a mistake, enlisted
Major Erns Block, a distinguished
veteran of
World War I and one of the most trusted
officers. Block was a Micheling. Okay, a
Michelin just means a German who had
some Jewish ancestry, but because he was
so valerous in World War I, he was
considered a German. Okay.
Um, he had been declared of German blood
by Hitler in 1939 along with three other
soldiers, two of whom were also missing.
Block was instructed to find Ysef Yad
and bring him to safety. Wow.
The Nazis, okay,
dispatched their own soldiers to find
this guy and bring him to America. And
this is again during war.
But how do you find this guy? Block and
his colleagues had to maneuver through
the ruins of Warsaw without arousing the
suspicions of the SS to find a rabbi who
did not know of their mission and did
not want to be found. Okay, so this
rabbi is hiding for everyone. So how do
you find this guy? and he's deadly
afraid of all German soldiers because he
sees them as just Nazis.
This is another problem. Well, Jews in
the city were naturally unwilling to
divulge the location of his leader to a
Nazi officer. Eventually, information
came from the Americans. Brendex was
informed of Ysef Yev's address by the
Shabbat lawyer Arthur Robinitz and relay
it via Cohen and Pel to the US charged
affairs in Germany. This requires a
coordination of dozens and dozens of
people who are supposed to be on the
opposite side of a war and they're
working together to achieve a goal.
Um, at the end of November, Block found
Ysef Yat's apartment and after some
confusion convinced the residents he was
there to help. Once he had obtained fuel
c coupons, train tickets and military
clearances for SS checkpoints block
loaded Ysef Yzvet and his family under
truck and headed for the train station.
There the family received first class
tickets and boarded a train filled with
Nazi officials and soldiers. Okay? And
that's how they got him out.
In other words, they are able to work
above the bureaucracy of different
nation states in order to achieve their
esquetological goal. Okay? All right.
Does it make sense? All right. So now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
into the idea of esquetological
convergence
because once we know the different
esquetologies and we know how they
converge together, we can actually make
certain predictions about how this war
will progress. Okay. So the first major
esquetology I want to look at is called
zoroastinism. And this is the first
esquetology and it's a it's a it's an
esquetology of the Persian Empire. Okay.
And this estology is very simple. In the
world there's truth and a lie. Okay. The
light and the darkness. And it it is our
responsibility as humans to live for the
light to die for the truth against the
lie. And at the end of days, there will
be a final battle and a day of judgment.
Okay? So, light
versus dark and then you have a day of
judgment.
Okay? Where the god aor master will come
down and he will create a paradise for
everyone. Okay? So what matters is to
live a noble life and await the day of
judgment where eventually
heaven on earth will manifest. Okay?
And this is important because if you
think about how the Iranians are
fighting this war, the Iranians refuse
to take the initiative and destroy too
much. Okay? They refuse to be the
villains in this war because for them in
their esquetology it's important to die
for the light to fight for the truth.
Okay. Now the Jewinism has a major
impact on uh Jewish esquetology. Okay.
And Jewish esotry again
I'm only talking about the most extreme
version of this estology. Okay? And in
this esquetology um the idea is that the
Jews disobeyed God. Okay, disobedience.
And what and in order to repair the
world to save themselves to great heaven
on earth, they need to engage in
redemption. Okay, redemption.
And redemption is really about spiritual
alchemy. Improving yourself as a person,
being good to yourself, being good to
others, loving your neighbor as though
you would love yourself. Okay, that's a
mainstream idea. But in in the most
extreme version, redemption just means
acting out God's plan to uh compel the
return of Messiah. Okay. And this plan
is basically um create Israel
um return Jewish diaspora,
build their temple
and this will lot call the war of Gog
and Magog.
And then when the Jews
are most threatened, the Messiah will
come to save them um from their enemies.
And this will create something called
the Mesagani age. Okay? When God rules
over the earth through his Messiah who
comes from the house of David. Okay? All
right. So again, this is a simple
version. There are lots of different
versions. This is the most simple
version for our purposes. Okay. Now
what's interesting is that this Jewish
esquetology would go on to influence the
Protestants. Okay. And this creates a
movement called Christian Zionism.
Christian Zionism.
Um so the technical word for Christian
Zionism is called premillennial
dispensationalism.
Okay. And this sounds very complicated,
but it's not. All it means is that God
has a plan
for how to create heaven on earth. And
we have a duty to fulfill his plan by
following his instructions. Okay. All
right. So what Christian Zionism is
doing is that it takes this Jewish
esquetology and makes certain changes to
it. Okay. So for example the first
change that it makes is okay this plan
is fine but rather than say that the
Jewish Messiah is the representative of
God what they say is that no he's
actually the representative of Satan.
Okay. So the Messiah
um in a Jewish tradition becomes the
antichrist
in the Christian Zionist tradition. And
why is this important? It's important
because for the Christians, the Messiah
must be Jesus. Okay? So the Messiah, so
the Antichrist, what he does is that he
rules over the world. He's very
charismatic and he rules the world in
Jerusalem and he starts a war of go war
of Gog and Magog
in order to conquer the world and
destroy the Jews. At this at this point
Jesus will return to save God's chosen
people, the Jews. And when Jesus
returns, there'll be something called
the rapture where all Christians will
immediately ascend to heaven. Okay. So,
the rapture.
All right. Okay. So, again, Christian
Zionism is working off Jewish
esquetology,
but it's making some important changes.
Okay. So, another way of saying this is
um in the beginning, Zionist and
Christian Zionist will work together to
reach a certain point of history. Okay.
What we call the great racial project.
But then they will diverge and fight
against each other. Okay? So they're
allies now, but eventually they'll turn
against each other. All right? So now
I'm going to talk about the Freemasons
because the Freemasons,
we'll talk more about the Freemasons
later, okay? The Freemasons are also
working within the Christian Zionist
context but they are much more focused
on actually how to implement this. Okay.
So what they want to do is they want to
take the antichrist and turn it into a
system.
And this system we discussed last
semester it's called Pax Judea.
What is P Judeica? Pap Judea is that um
Israel controls the world through AI.
Okay. An AI surveillance state.
Okay. Or their exact words is holy
empire.
Okay. and patch Judea the state will
things such as the mark of the beast
and what is the mark of the beast
it is digital ID
okay and this digital ID will also lead
to digital currency and they can
actually put a microchip or a QR bar in
your forehead and this will be
considered the mark of the beast okay
and this all part of the Christian Zag
estology Um, another really important
thing about the free basins is the idea
of a one world government
because remember the antichrist is the
leader of a one world government and
it'll be based in Jerusalem. Okay. And
so the headquarters will be Solomon's
temple or the third temple.
All right. Okay. So these are the u and
then you have the Islamic esquetology.
Okay. in in in the Islamic esquetology
is a response to all these other
esquetologies
where
they say that when the system is created
it'll be called dajel
dajel the antichrist okay and when this
happens then Jesus will return
to defeat the antichrist okay that's the
mainstream Islamic esquetology then you
have the shia
okay the shia
remember are the Iranians where they
believe that it's not it will be the 12
Iman Mad
who will lead
um the followers okay the Umrah okay um
just means community of follow of
believers the believers
into victory
against the antichrist the dah okay so
you can see how these esoters are
basically lining up together, right? The
Shia or the Iranians. The Islamic is the
entire Arab world. Right? Now, there are
other two more esquetologies I I want to
look at. And again, I know this is a
lot. I know this is too much
information. And we'll go over these
esquetologies specifically as we move
along, okay? But I just want to
introduce the different esquetologies.
Another esquetology that's very
important is the Catholic esquetology.
And in the Catholic esquetology we can
call city of God
okay which is the church
which is Jerusalem
and St. Augustine uh talks about this
about how the Catholic church it is the
millennium it is the messianic age
because we represent God and we bring
peace and prosperity to the world. Now
what's important about the church is
that it became the dominant power in the
world because Rome fell. Okay? So Roman
Empire collapses.
But this is all part of God's divine
plan because Roman Empire Rome was the
city of
earth. Okay? Of power, of money, of
wealth. And what matters is Jerusalem,
the city of God, of spirituality,
of um divinity. Okay. Now, the city of
God came to an end because of the rise
of the Protestants and the
Anglo-American Empire.
So for the Catholic Church to achieve
its esquetology and establish again the
city of God, what they need to do is
also see the Anglo American Empire
destroyed just like the Roman Empire.
Okay. So that is the Catholic
esquetology. The last esque esquetology
I want to discuss is the Orthodox
esquetology. And what's the Orthodox
esquetology?
the Russians. Okay,
this is called the third Rome prophecy.
Okay, the third Rome prophecy is
basically that Moscow
will become the third Rome. Okay, the
first Rome of the first Rome was Rome,
second Rome was consip, the third Rome
will be Moscow. And also what's really
important to uh appreciate is that there
will be no fourth Rome. So when Moscow
becomes a third Rome, history ends.
Okay. And peace and prosperity will come
to the world. Okay. So so what does this
mean? It means that Russia will will
unite the Orthodox world.
Okay. So right now the Orthodox world is
split into Eastern Orthodox Sea um and
Greek Orthodox Sea. Okay. And something
that is very important that this
prophecy says is that the Russians will
defeat Turkey in a war and then have the
Greeks return to Kasanapole which is
modern day Istanbul. Okay, that's what
the prophecy says. And so you look at
all these different esquetologies. Okay.
And again guys, this is the majority of
the world, right? If you actually look
at the convergence points, you come to
some startling
um conclusions. Okay, so let's look at
the convergence.
All right, where do they converge? Okay.
Well, first of all, okay, where they
converge is that the greater
Israel project
will be achieved. Okay. Pax Judea will
be achieved.
It's a one world government. Okay. One
world government.
That is one major con convergence. If
that's true, then another convergence is
the lxic moss will give way to the third
temple.
All these esquetologies either say this
or indifferent to saying this. Okay,
they're not opposed to this. All right,
so that's that's why I predict the third
uh the Alex moss will be destroyed
because they need to build a third
temple. Another thing which in which um
they converge is the rise of
anti-semitism.
Why? Because that will force the
diaspora, the Jewish diaspora to return
to Israel. This is very important for
this esquetology. Okay. All right.
Another important convergence point is
the war of Gog and Magog.
We don't actually know what this is, but
this war is supposed to be the final war
before the return of God, before the end
of history, before the end of the world.
Okay. What this war is, we don't know
yet. But another saying this is that
this war in Iran will lead to the war of
Gaga Magog at some point. Okay. What
this war is, we'll discuss at a later
time. Another thing that's very
important is
US and China
are not part of this esquetology.
Okay, this is where everyone agrees. For
whatever reason, the United States is
not going to partake in future events.
neither will China which means that
um something will happen to these two
countries that will make them not
significant anymore. Okay. And the best
prediction for United States then is
civil war. Right. Okay. Civil war.
Okay. And this is where
um all these esquetologies converge. So
in other words this waring event is
happening so that these different
esquetological tradition can achieve
um heaven on earth from their
perspective. All right. So what this
mean so given this convergence we we
actually predict certain events that
will happen over the next two to four
years. Okay.
Because they all want these things to
happen together. All right. So let's
look at some quick predictions.
Okay, first prediction of course is that
the US will use ground troops
because using ground troops will create
a national draft.
And what does a national draft do? It
creates a civil war, right? A lot of
young people are going to refuse to
fight in this war. And this this going
to create protest then America will have
no choice but to deploy the national
guard and this will create the recipe
for a lot of civil conflict in America.
Okay. Another thing that will happen is
because you use ground troops you will
lose the war and then sencom which is
the American military in Middle East
will then transfer over to Israel.
Okay.
What's happening in this war is that the
economies of the GCC
are being destroyed and that's part of
the plan. Okay? Because for Israel to
achieve the Greater Israel project, it
needs to absorb the GCC and parts of
Turkey and parts of Egypt. Okay? So
saying this is that the GCC is basically
finished. The intention is to collapse
their economies and make them
irrelevant.
Right? The third thing we can expect is
that Turkey
will enter this war and Saudi Arabia
actually will enter the war
because you want to use this war to
weaken opposition to these esquetologies
as much as possible. Okay. So, Tea and
Saudi will enter this war and they will
suffer tremendously because of their
participation.
All right.
Um again the Alex at Mos will be
destroyed.
Okay. And then you have the rise of
Persia.
Okay. The rise of Persia. Why is this
important? Because um you need the Zic
world to unite against Israel for the
end of days, right? So you don't mind if
actually Iran wins this war because by
winning this war Iran will activate its
Persian identity. And this is important
for esquetology because in the war of
Gaga Magog
people are interpreting Gog and Magog
which will march against Israel. They're
interpreting Gogg to be Persia and
Russia. Okay.
Okay. Together they will ma march
against Pax Judeica. Number six is that
in Israel you will achieve the Pax
Judeica
and the Greater Israel project.
Okay. So the greater Israel project and
Pax Juda are not the same thing guys.
Greater Israel is is just basically the
territory
that the Israelites believed that God
had promised their ancestor Abraham. P
Judea is a one world government, okay?
Based on AI surveillance and the mark of
the beast. So um what will happen is
that um Israel will use this war to
expand its territory and then what will
happen is that capital technology
um will then start to flow to Israel in
order to create the great patria. So
think of companies like Nvidia, Oracle,
Microsoft, Google. Well, they'll
probably transfer themselves to Israel
because that is where the power will
rest. Okay. Um so Pax Judea
um then you will have
um Russia
winning a war in Ukraine. Okay.
And then um return Greeks to
Constantinopole.
Basically, another way we're saying this
is it is possible that um
the Greeks go to war against Tokia and
then Russia supports the Greeks and
return the Greeks to symbol. Okay, but
then you're like, wait a minute, Toka is
a NATO member.
Well, we can also expect
destruction of of
Europe. Okay, the end of NATO basically.
So this war Ukraine, it's not just about
Russia protecting its borders. This war
Ukraine is also meant to achieve
orthodox esquetology to destroy Europe
to destroy NATO so that Russia can
achieve the third Rome prophecy that
means the destruction of Europe. So I
will discuss the Russian Ukraine war
later on as as we go along. Okay. But
what what I'm trying to show you is that
just by okay analyzing the most extreme
esquetologies of different religious
traditions,
you can then from this analysis pick out
points in which they agree. Okay? And
when and at these points you can figure
out then how they will affect
current geopolitics to make certain
predictions about how the war will
progress about how the world will
transform itself in the next 2 to four
years. Okay. So this is called the law
of esqueological convergence. It gives
us tremendous insight into why things
are turned out the way they are. Okay.
Because again, I keep on saying this,
but purely from a geopolitical
perspective, purely from a real politic
perspective, this war in Iran makes no
sense.
But if you look at from an
esquetological perspective, then it
makes perfect sense. Okay, any
questions?
Yes.
But I think like if we look uh into the
war between America and Iran um I think
Trump is trying to destroy Iran as the
same way that he destroys Venezora but
it fails which um led Iran to fight
back. So I think this could also explain
in a political way but not religious.
>> Okay.
All right. That's a great point in that
listen, there's an explanation which is
that Trump is just stupid. He's
arrogant. They had too much success in
Venezuela. They go into Iran and they
think it's the same thing. And now
they're losing. Okay. And because
they're losing
um they are just panicking. Okay. Okay.
That's true. And um if this explanation
is true, then what will happen? What we
can expect to happen is that Trump
declares victory and goes home.
Okay, that's what what we can expect.
Um,
and if if US does go home, then you're
right. Okay, so
we can expect but sorry. Um, the
question is what happens next few
months? All right,
what you need to understand is this. Um,
war is that simple. Once you start a
war, you can't end the war. All right.
So, let me explain very really quickly
why. Okay. So, you have Iran and the
main thing the main advantage that Iran
has over the United States is the GCC
cannot defend itself. Okay? Because it's
just a desert and Iran it's a mountain
fortress. So, it can shoot rockets. It
can shoot drones at the GCC and the GC
can't can't defend itself. Okay? Before
they thought these US bases could defend
against Iran, but now you recognize
these US bases can't defend themselves
either. Okay. All right. So, um the
other thing that Iran does did was close
off the trade of Hum.
Okay. He closed off the trade of Hum.
And this is important because the GCC
then
um exports
oil to Asia and gets back food. Okay. So
the GCC basically requires just strives
uh in order just to survive. Okay. Now
let's just say the US Donald Trump's
like, "You know what? Screw this. This
is a stupid war. The Middle East is
stupid. We're going to go home." Okay.
What happens now? What happens is that
Iran says to GCC, "Hey man, you attacked
us. You destroyed our infrastructure.
You destroyed our economy. You have to
pay
pay a rent pay a compensation. Okay.
Right. Also, hey man, now we control the
stable moves. So if you want to
um useful moves, you have to pay us a
toll. You have to pay us a tax,
right? So all this money of the GCC
before it's going to United States um to
fuel the US economy. Now where does it
go? It goes to Iran,
right? That's a lot of money, man. We're
talking about trillions and trillions of
dollars. And what what will Iran use
with this money? It will use its money
this money to repair its economy. So in
5 10 years, this is going to be an
economic miracle
where now Iran is able to industrialize,
really fast. And as a result, what's
going to happen? What's going to happen
is that United States leaves the Middle
East. Iran becomes the superpower
and controls the entire Middle East
right now. What now? Israel has nuclear
weapons. And so what's going to happen
is that Israel and Iran will sign a
peace treaty. Okay? But the United
States
won't be involved. United States goes
home. It doesn't get any money from the
GCC. What's going to happen to the US
economy? It's going to collapse. Why?
Because the entire US economy is based
on the stock market, on finance, on AI,
on investment from the GCC, right? So
the question then is, can Americans go
home? The answer is no, they can't.
Because if they go home, their economy
is going to collapse and the people are
going to have a revolution anyway. So
you're better off sending people to Iran
than have the people in America cause a
revolution, right? Okay. So, you're
right in that it's possible that Donald
Trump made a mistake, but doesn't matter
if it was intentional or accidental. You
have the same outcome and and strangely
enough, the strange out this outcome
that you have matches that aligns with
these different esquetologies in the
world. Okay. Does that make sense? Okay.
All right. Any more questions?
All right. Okay. So, we'll continue this
next week, guys. Okay.